Country was encoded by color hue.
Game win or losses was encoded by position y or orientation.
Scoring margin was encoded by position Y or length.
World Cup winners were indicated by shape, and time was encoded by position X.
Let's see these on the graphic.
We can see the country is encoded by the color of the bars, or
really each country has its own panel of data.
So, Germany would be red, Brazil would be green, Argentina blue and
The Netherlands orange.
Each of these bars represents an individual game and
the scoring margin for that game.
So, whether or not a game was a win or
loss depends on the Y position, or the orientation of the bar.
Bars that point upwards indicate wins for
Germany, while bars that point downward indicate losses for Germany.
The actual scoring margin for each game is the length of the bar.
In this case it looks like about positive 3.
We also accepted position Y since the scoring margin could be positive upward,
or downward negative.
Time is encoded horizontally along the x-axis for each of our small multiples.
And then finally, whether or not a country was a World Cup winner is encoded
by shape or a star, which we see for Germany in 1954, 1974 and 1990.
Now I think this visualization is quite successful.
And what's incredible is that there's even more going on in it,
such as the annotations that you see here, and
the alternation between this white and light tan background encoding the years.
If you find other things that you like about this visualization,
share it on the discussion threads.